bonjour madame
on est en direct dans trente secondes
vous connaissez les missions perdu de
vue perdu de vue les enfants ou les
personnes qui veulent oui on enquête sur
une personne qui a disparu depuis quatre
ans une dame qui a sensiblement votre
âge on l'avait retrouvé ont l'art perdu
il ya la famille sur le plateau on
voudrait que vous fassiez un petit
témoignage on verra pas votre visage on
dit que vous êtes geneviève de
saint-agil je vous poser trois questions
10 secondes 10 secondes dakar eh bien
oui nous avons retrouvé geneviève de
saint-agil après une disparition de plus
de 4 années alors geneviève
où étiez-vous pendant toutes ces années
je n'en avais mardi ciel gris de paris
et je voulais aller voir le où se
trouvait le soleil malgré moi et vous
dit que vos deux enfants josélito et
mongolito sont en larmes
il vous regarde dina qui a huit mois un
autre 37 ans qu'est ce que vous avez à
leur dire à vos enfants et salut les
gars salut ça va c'est papa alors je
reviens bientôt à la maison c'est pas
ton écoute ça ne riez pas c'est une
émission dramatique et il ya famille sur
le plateau enfin comme but que je suis
homosexuel que j'ai vendu mon corps et
que j'ai une petite cervelle d'oiseau
mais je crois que ce sont des larmes de
la sincérité
séquence émotion c'est vous qui revenez
à evry après quinze années de
disparition nous avons enfin retrouver
le capitaine craddock le capital
craddock
où étiez-vous capitaine depuis ses 15
ans ces quinze ans vous avez disparu où
étiez-vous capitaine mois genève
vous avez fait naufrage au large du cap
horn et depuis plus de nouvelles
ce qui s'est passé pendant toutes ces
années
alors alors junior vous vendez toujours
votre corps ah non non non traitement
sortie maintenant de la prostitution
on vivait maintenant exclusivement que
de la drogue non plus et là on attendait
on va faire des larmes parce que c'est
ses battants des jeunes mon truc a
essayé d'accéder du cinéma ne soyez pas
tranché la tête en arrière ne seriez pas
messieurs c'est l'émotion à l'état pur
allez vous pleurez vous pleurez plus te
prend désormais lire d'accord vous
l'aimez toujours oui bien sûr merci manu
qui n'assistent pas vous êtes
visiblement à bout de nerfs
c'est très très beau ccc poignant c'est
sexy tort et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus